hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about potassium in
relationship to your cardiovascular
system this little video is based on a
really cool article that I put down
there to download if you have any
cardiovascular problems you need to read
this article this is called the new
guideline for potassium replacement in
clinical practice so it's a group of
cardiologists who formed the National
Council on potassium and they show the
importance of potassium for the
cardiovascular system so I want to just
kind of cover some of the summaries in
what potassium can do first of all if
you have a potassium deficiency the name
of that disorder is called hypo Kali mia
hypo and you can remember by kail ka le
right hypokalemia that's low potassium
now if you have a potassium deficiency
you might feel tired leg cramps muscle
weakness constipated tremor because
potassium is intimately involved with
muscle physiology neurophysiology and
cardiovascular physiology so you can
also have atrial fibrillation which is a
rhythm problem of the heart high blood
pressure in fact in most cases of high
blood pressure there is a potassium
deficiency and what do they give you a
diuretic what is diuretics do most of
them deplete potassium so it's like a
never-ending cycle and then also if
you're low on potassium you will have a
higher pulse rate potassium lowers your
pulse rate okay so now the question is
how could you possibly get a potassium
deficiency right well here are some of
the causes one is maybe too much sodium
because when you increase sodium you
naturally decrease potassium because
they work together but maybe it's not
potassium maybe it's low manganese or
magnesium sir magnesium so when you
magnesium is necessary to keep potassium
in the right balance and that comes from
the vegetables all right
insulin high insulin so let's say you
have insulin resistance or you're
diabetic you know that you're not going
to be able to absorb potassium that well
and that's why you there's always a
diamond fluid
choose in fact it takes potassium to
heal the insulin dysfunction
you can almost correct insulin
resistance and improve your blood
Sugar's by taking potassium fascinating
and then of course too much sugar from
the spike insulin will actually deplete
potassium too many refined carbs will do
it that's why if you consume a lot of
sugar all of a sudden your pulse rate
starts going higher also high cortisol
that's the stress also in a camera a
medication called prednisone that can
also deplete your potassium of course
you have the diarrhea and vomiting to
some degree and then also a condition
called alkalosis alkalosis is when your
body is just too alkaline
and I know you've been taught that
people need to just alkalize the body
and all this stuff well actually when
you go through a lot of stress and you
have high levels of cortisol your
adrenal body type your pH becomes more
on the alkaline side your blood pH
becomes excessively alkaline and that's
called PAL Colossus and one of the
symptoms is a potassium deficiency
interesting right surgery in trauma when
they do a major abdominal surgery you
you're always watching for potassium
because that potassium goes down when
you're under the SIRT under surgery and
you're already deficient potassium you
can create some serious problems with
the heart so that's why they used to
give you a potassium IV when you go
through surgery and then trauma I
remember I had a bike accident went over
the handlebars and I let in the cement
and my potassium just went down to zero
and I think because when you when you go
through stress it spikes adrenaline
adrenaline will decrease potassium too
and then we have low hydrochloric acid
when you don't have enough acid your
stomach you can't absorb potassium and
then you have potassium problems so it
takes potassium to keep the stomach
acids correct and also taking potassium
will help you digest and create stomach
acids so so in other words low potassium
can create low hydrochloric acid but
then adding acid back in can help you
absorb potassium drinking too much water
or can deplete your potassium because
water is not necessarily filled with
electrolytes so you take too much water
you drink a gallon and you deplete the
last bit of potassium you have and then
you end up why with all sorts of
dehydration problems right diuretic
that's another cause of potassium
deficiencies and that comes from when
you're on high blood pressure they give
you the relic and then you become the
task and deficient and then you state
you continue to have high blood pressure
crazy so in this article that I want you
to download these doctors are
recommending potassium to prevent and
even correct a lot of the cardiovascular
problems and potassium has the potential
to creep your arteries elastic decrease
the risk of the stroke and potassium can
protect the kidney and even the heart so
this whole idea that if you have a
kidney problem you absolutely must stay
away from potassium is not necessarily
true unless it's a severe case now how
do you get potassium beet tops okay but
if you don't like the DB tops you just
need to start to increase your salad to
seven to ten cups of salad why because
it takes that much potassium and we need
a lot like close to forty seven hundred
milligrams potassium is also good for
rheumatoid arthritis inflammatory
conditions so you can see this mineral
is vital so for more information about
nutrition and health and how to create a
healthy body check out my website at dr.
Berg com I'll see you there